to France now when more protests are
underway against the government's plans
to raise the retirement age these are
live pictures of protesters facing off
with police and then demonstrators have
also blocked ramps and Roads outside of
charl De Gaulle Airport near Paris
forcing passengers to get there on foot
in other cities union members have been
blocking roads they're all demanding
macron dropped the pension Bill
something he refused to do in a public
address on Wednesday let's bring in our
correspondent Natasha Butler she's
joining us live from Paris so what's
happening where you are Natasha
okay
well I'm sure you can see behind me
there are thousands of people filling
this Square the plaster La Bastian
Central Paris they're going to be
walking uh across the city surely I
think in front the the front of the
demonstration has already left but there
are people still coming in to this
Square from uh all around there's been a
lot of disruption today it is another
Nationwide strike and protest date the
ninth since the beginning of the year
and that's affecting uh across the
public sector transport hubs education
uh Health Services garbage is still
piling up in Paris a lot of anger over
president macro's pension uh Reform Bill
which will raise the retirement age but
not only that people are now Angry over
the method by which president macro's
government pushed this bill through
Parliament bypassing lawmakers and MPS
they forced it through by decree people
say that just shows the president
mackerel cares not not only does he not
care I should say about people in the
street and their concerns but he also
doesn't care about Francis Institute
they say about lawmakers about
opposition and critics that he only
cares about what he wants and
interestingly he was saying that what he
wants is progress for the country and
his televised address and that he
doesn't care about his popularity
because he can't run for president again
um just how vulnerable is he
there's no doubt that President mackerel
is under a lot of pressure socially and
politically look politically it was just
a few days ago that macros uh government
just about survived and no confidence
Motion in Parliament by just a few votes
because of the level of anger and
opposition and criticism uh in the
parliament now that's going to make it
very difficult to go forward with other
legislation in the future because there
are so many divisions in Parliament and
so much animosity towards the government
and president macro president macro says
that this reform is fundamental in order
to sustain the pension system for the
future as you said he says I don't care
about my popularity what's important is
my duty to the country he said those
things in a television interview but
that interview has really added fuel to
the fire if you like because he gave no
concessions to any of his opponents he
said he wouldn't reshuffle his cabinet
he wouldn't for example change his prime
minister that is in inflamed attentions
and passions even more if you like so
it's very interesting to see which way
things are going to go the government
and macro of course would like these uh
protests to fizzle out but demonstrators
are saying that even though this bill is
on its way to becoming a law they don't
care they're going to continue to go out
in the streets because they want to put
enough pressure on the government so
that it scraps its reform Natasha thank
you very much for that that is Natasha
Butler joining us with the very latest
from the protests in Paris